[Musique]
Ibrahima Moussa
Omar samba tout ça arrive de la rue la
plupart d'entre eux ont fugué de leur
école coranique le Dara pour échapper au
cou et à la mendicité forcée
livré à eux-mêmes ses enfants aéré dans
les rues pendant des jours des mois
parfois même des années sans revoir leur
famille
la situation de ces petits animés
existent depuis 50 ans dans les grandes
villes du Sénégal il ne cesse de
s'aggraver
[Musique]
dans l'intimité protégée du refuge on
travaille photo m'a permis d'engager
avec eux un premier dialogue muet et
complice tandis qu'il découvrait ses
nouvelles images de même leurs yeux me
révélaient chaque jour l'intensité des
émotions qui les habitait
[Musique]
peu à peu il me fait comprendre qu'ils
étaient prêts à prendre la parole je ne
savais pas encore qu'ils allaient me
raconter une seule et même histoire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au début ils disaient que j'attaque
la même chose
j'ai attaqué le business de la mendicité
des enfants c'est ça que j'ai attaqué
ma propre religion
mais maintenant c'est c'est une disons
une une réaction corporatiste
qui disait que si tout le monde pense
comme lui nous allons plus exister on va
nous allons disparaître etc notre
business va disparaître sur notre
business ont disparu non il faut le
faire comprendre non
dites-nous quels sont les solutions
ensemble nous cherchons une manière que
vous puissiez gagner votre vie à travers
votre métier qui est d'enseigner le
Coran un métier c'est pour pouvoir en
vivre donc on dise pas que renseigner le
Coran doit être une activité gratuite au
fond ce n'est pas grave dans la mesure
[Musique]
il est fort
je pense que on a beau dire
je crois que il faut en jeter le double
sur nous-mêmes
nous sommes nous nous sommes nous sommes
le carburant
mais aussi
lui donner une bougie
sachez de lait tout cela ça règle plutôt
de ce que j'appelait vulgairement la
sorcellerie le charlotte a fait que
le citoyen
sénégalais et j'ai pourtant menti je
peux dire que tous les citoyens
sénégalais sont responsables parce que
quand ils vont consulter un marabout
pour leur faire l'oracle
ils doivent donner une charité il y en a
qui chaque matin s'il donne pas le monde
il croit qu'ils sont foutus
donc voilà donc ils se sentent en danger
donc chaque matin c'est des sachets de
lait caille
du sucre des bougies un peu de riz mais
que après
le monde s'est transformé au
progressivement donc c'est des pièces de
10 francs c'est des pièces de 25 francs
c'est des pièces de 50 francs et il y en
a même qui donne qui donne 1000 francs
moi je crois que c'est quelque chose qui
est qui est dans le sang qui est dans la
tête donc il n'est pas facile à
éradiquer
donc ne disons pas au Sénégal arrêter le
monde
on dit il faut arrêter la Malicité la
mendicité c'est quelque chose c'est
presque une maladie incurable
il faut seulement arrondir mes angles
dire qu'est-ce qu'on veut retirer de la
vie moi c'est l'enfant parce que la
place de l'enfant ce n'est pas la rue
donc le Sénégalais doit prendre
conscience de ce phénomène
[Musique]
et qui va le faire manger il le sait
bien il le sait très bien lui aussi le
barabout c'est bien aussi que son papa
là il lui a donné son enfant pour s'en
débarrasser quelque part
chaque jour maintenant dans le registre
religieux en disant que Dieu vous a
donné la grande capacité de nous éduquer
nos enfants de manière religieuse et
vous qui dernier le Coran on peut pas
vous payer même pour ça et c'est même
discours qui connaît en train de te dire
à l'heure actuelle
faut pas faire la politique de
l'Autriche tout ce que les gens pour
dire il le pense tout bas
je pense que l'État s'y prend souvent
très mal
des fois
par un bout seulement alors que le
premier global
je vous dis il y a le parent il y a le
marabout il y a l'état et il y a le
citoyen il faut que il y ait une sorte
de disons de commission je sais pas moi
en tout cas un lieu de dialogue
permanent
entités sont représentées et discutent
mais de manière disons réaliste et est
vrai ce qu'on veut c'est
amener les mêmes coraniques et avoir des
alternatives pour la mendicité ce n'est
pas tout le monde qui m'a dit ce n'est
pas tous les maîtres coraniques dans qui
font manier il y en a qui ne le font pas
il y en a qui ont déjà trouvé une
alternative c'est il crée ce qu'ils
appellent une école franco-arabe où on
étudie l'arabe et le français alors les
gosses qui fréquent cette école là ils
payent mensuellement et c'est le fruit
de tout ça qu'ils utilisent pour
entretenir le Dara qui est à côté et qui
ne manque plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour madame
[Musique]
ça va
ok merci
le téléphone à
à la famille de balle pour que je puisse
parler à
par rapport à ces intégration et surtout
en famille
c'est vraiment à la carte tu poses
jamais savoir si l'enfant est prêt pour
rester et tu peux jamais aussi dire à
quel moment je vais retourner l'enfant
parce que il est pas prêt d'abord pour
quitter la rue après la laisser n'est
pas prêt pour retourner dans sa famille
c'est pas du tout facile pour nous de se
prononcer par rapport à tout cela il
faut que l'enfant soit en sécurité il
faut que l'enfant sent que moi là les
gens qui m'accompagnent sont prêts à
tout faire pour que ma famille puisse
m'accepter tel que je suis
bientôt
[Musique]
depuis à peu près une trentaine d'années
les gouvernants n'ont pas eu le courage
politique de radicaux
à notre niveau au niveau le plus bas de
l'échelle administrative la commune se
dit
il y a une loi qui date de presque 15
ans sur l'interdiction qui n'a jamais
été appliqué mais qui n'a pas été abrogé
Nice alors on se dit nous on va comme on
est une commune de plein exercice on va
faire un acte
à notre dimension c'est la rétine
municipale pour interdire la mendicité
et aujourd'hui l'État qui a la mission
régalienne de sauvegarder la dignité
humaine et de ses citoyens et obligé de
s'investir mais nous nous attendons pas
l'état nous devons continuer le combat
et de plus en plus aussi on a vu que
certains mecs coraniques des actes
maintenant la commune parce que ça
change que nous avons national qui va
nous permettre de mobiliser toutes les
énergies pour faire la grande offensive
n'est ce pas contre la mendicité je
pense que quelque part aussi la peur va
changer de camp maintenant le maître
coranique sera que son statut a
complètement changé et que il n'est plus
maître des lieux le voir le petit dieu
qui sait tout qui peut faire tout non
maintenant les gens lui diront basta
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui puisque jamais nous sommes
décidés
des personnes et donc c'est toute une
mafia organisée autour de la recherche
effrénée du gain de l'argent qui fait
que les gens n'ont plus de scrupules
n'hésites devant rien pour eux les
enfants sont des objets c'est des moyens
pour pouvoir s'enrichir et on demande
donc il y a tellement de choses que même
si on les donne ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas parce qu'on est méchant mais parce
qu'on veut développer parce qu'on veut
assainir une société qui qui tend à
l'explosion parce que l'enfant qui passe
une quinzaine d'années dans la rue c'est
peut-être un terroriste potentiel c'est
aussi un criminel qui à la limite si il
n'a pas d'argent il va voler s'il peut
pas avaler tranquille il va utiliser les
armes donc c'est c'est vraiment une
bombe en gestation c'est phénomène de
garçon d'enfants de la rue donc il faut
que tout le monde se mette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'ai voulu faire ce film du point de vue
de l'enfant en montrant que cet enfant
l'idée que l'enfant né avec toute son
intelligence à partir de ce moment je
dis ce gosse
si je prends le temps essaie dans son
coin de vue
il va développer des choses en disant
que je suis honnête comme toi j'ai le
même droit que toi pourquoi tu me
tortures pourquoi tu me fais travailler
pourquoi j'ai pas droit de l'affection
de ma maman pourquoi toi en tant que
parents qui prend pas tes responsabilité
à partir de ce mois aussi j'ai enfin net
contestataire finalement subversif qu'il
apprenne à travers ce film à se prendre
en charge avoir le sens de
responsabilité
le centre de la dignité le sens de la
liberté consoles pas faire des choses
hors norme
quelqu'un que fait des injustices
refusent révolte toi
[Musique]